you
literary critic north of fry once
observed that in our primitive days our
literary heroes were well nearly gods
and as civilization advanced they came
down the mountain of the gods so to
speak and became more human more flawed
less heroic from the divine heroes like
Hercules down the mountain below the
miraculous but mortal heroes such as
Beowulf the great leaders such as King
Arthur and the great put flawed heroes
like Macbeth or Othello below even the
unlikely but eventual heroes such as
Harry Potter Luke Skywalker or hiccup
until we reached the bottom and meet the
antihero contrary to the sound the
antihero is not the villain not the
antagonist the antihero is actually the
main character in some contemporary
works of literature Guy Montag in
Fahrenheit 451 Winston Smith in 1984 who
unwittingly ends up challenging those in
power that is those who abuse their
power to brainwash the populace to
believe that the ills of society have
been eliminated ideally those who
challenge the establishment should be
wise confident brave physically strong
with a type of charisma that inspires
followers the antihero however at best
demonstrates a few underdeveloped traits
at worst is totally inept the story of
the antihero usually unfolds something
like this the antihero initially
conforms ignorantly accepting the
established views a typical
unquestioning brainwashed member of
society
the antihero struggles to conform all
the while starting to object perhaps
finding other Outsiders with whom to
voice his questions and naively unwisely
sharing those questions with an
authority figure the antihero openly
challenges society and tries to fight
against the lies and tactics used to
oppress the populace
this step for the anti-hero is seldom a
matter of brave wise and heroic
opposition may be the anti-hero fights
and succeeds in destroying the
impressive government with a lot of
impossible luck perhaps he or she runs
away escapes to fight another day
all too often though the antihero is
killed or brainwashed to return to
conformity with the masses no heroic
triumphs fear no brave individuals
standing up against impersonal
institutions of a modern world inspiring
others to fight or resourcefully
outwitting and outgunning
the massive army of the evil empire our
storytelling ancestors combed our fears
of powerlessness by giving us Hercules
and other heroes strong enough to fight
off the demons and monsters that we
suspected haunted the night beyond our
campfires but eventually we realized the
monsters did not lie out there they
reside inside of us BAE Wolf's greatest
enemy was mortality Othello's jealousy
hiccup self-doubt and in the tales of
the ineffectual antihero in the stories
of Guy Montag and Winston Smith lie the
warnings of contemporary storytellers
playing on very primitive fears that we
are not strong enough to defeat the
monsters
only this time not the monsters chased
away by the campfire but the very
monsters who built the campfire in the
first place